E aí
[Música]
e qual o seu futuro provável essa
pergunta imaginar a resposta dessa
pergunta mudou a minha vida mudou a
minha vida a primeira vez e mudou a
minha vida uma segunda vez na segunda
vez foi mais fácil porque eu já entendi
é isso eu quero trazer esse
questionamento para você mas antes de
trazer esse questionamento eu quero que
você entenda como que esse pensamento
como que imaginar como seria o meu
futuro fazendo que eu estava fazendo há
um tempo atrás mudou a minha vida quando
eu tinha mais ou menos nove dez anos de
idade eu assistir a shows de várias
bandas grandes internacionais e eu
assisti aquele show e me vinha uma
vontade um desejo enorme de estar no
palco fazendo shows para milhares de
pessoas igual aquelas bandas que eu
estava admirando na televisão fazia e
esse desejo era muito forte e eu
é que quando a gente tem um desejo muito
profundo automaticamente as nossas ações
até inconscientemente começam a nos
Direcionar para realizar esse desejo
então ali depois dos nove dez anos eu
lembro que eu tinha esse desejo muito
forte eu comecei a aprender a tocar
guitarra como se aprender tocar violão e
lógico as primeiras coisas que passava
pela minha cabeça era montar uma banda
para conseguir realizar esse desejo de
Infância montei a minha primeira banda
aos 13 anos de idade Passamos um período
de um ano ensaiando e a o medo o medo de
Exposição bloqueou essa primeira banda
minha a gente era muito jovem a gente
ficou um ano e sai ano quando a gente
teve oportunidade de fazer um primeiro
show ninguém da banda apareceu no dia do
show para fazer esse evento depois essa
banda acabou Depois deste momento eu vim
morar em Belo
o interior de Minas sobre uma cidade que
chama Itaobim vim morar em Belo
Horizonte com 15 anos e lógico com esse
desejo forte de mim forte dentro de mim
de fazer shows para milhares de pessoas
já sabia tocar já estava preparado para
começar um projeto e começa a fazer
shows E aí a vim fazer um ensino médio
Belo Horizonte e consegui da mesma forma
montar uma banda aqui em Belo Horizonte
começamos a ensaiar Montamos nosso
projeto e comecei comecei ali foi uma
semente onde eu comecei a caminhar em
direção desse desejo profundo meu
comecei a fazer shows em festivais
culturas em Belo Horizonte comecei a
fazer shows em boates nada grandioso e
na maioria dos shows eram até shows
gratuitos mas eu já tava sentindo assim
uma felicidade como eu nunca vi a
sentindo antes na minha vida eu tava
vivendo começando viver aquilo que eu
sou
é bem fácil e aí chegou o final do
terceiro ano e o que que acontece no
final de ser humano o nosso meio várias
pessoas começam a nos influenciar
principalmente a nossa família e e por
proteção né gente por proteção Por Amor
eles querem escolher o nosso destino
eles querem escolher um caminho que eles
acreditam que seja melhor que a gente e
como a influência da nossa família é
muito grande porque a ali com 17 18 anos
a gente não tem maturidade o suficiente
são poucas as pessoas que têm maturidade
suficiente para tomar uma decisão forte
enfrentar tudo e todos eu não tive essa
maturidade com a cidade com 17 e 18 anos
e no final do 3º ano a minha banda
acabou porque a família Nossa de todos
da banda tá me funcionário vocês tem que
fazer uma
e vocês tem que ter isso é garantido se
vocês formar em medicina em Direito
vocês terão uma vida é segura tranquila
até porque eu acredito que até hoje
essas profissões são consideradas a um
caminho seguro pelo menos na cabeça do
das famílias das da nossa família a você
médico você advogado eu vou ter uma
segurança financeira coisa que na
realidade não é assim que funciona mas
enfim cheguei e meu pai é médico acho
que ele conhecia é maior do que na
maioria das pessoas que não tinha pais
médicos E aí o meu pai me influenciando
me forçando me levava até para o
hospital para acompanhar os atendimentos
dele a estruturada e falar agora estou
estruturando isso para vocês para você
foi um começo é muito forte a para que
eu estudasse fizesse medicina decidi
falei tá vou fazer isso que você tá
querendo ir
a estudar fazer cursinho e eu percebia
Eu quero uma agonia fazer esse curso
para mim porque eu tentava estudar e eu
não conseguia às vezes eu até conseguia
esforçar por uma semana duas semanas
consegui estudar muito mas na terceira
semana não conseguia falar O Moça por
que que eu não consigo me dedicar se eu
não consigo deixar não vou conseguir
entrar em medicina e fiquei assim como
eu não conseguia me esforçar passou um
ano isso é realidade inclusive muitos de
vocês que vão assistir a essa
apresentação passou um ano de cursinho e
Lógico não passei nem perto de entrar em
medicina começou o 2º ano de cursinho é
da mesma forma eu tentava eu não
conseguia me esforçar não conseguia me
esforçar para passar em medicina até que
chegou o momento que teve um vestibular
tava começando aquele vestibulares que
você fazer uma prova
em uma nota você poderia escolher o
curso que você entrar eu fiz a prova
para entrar em medicina lógico como é o
nome dedicava a minha nota não deu para
entrar em medicina e eu acabei entrando
foi o papel aí minha nossa chover qual
curso o que que minha família vai
aceitar que meu meio é aceitar lá Achei
um que Odontologia vou começar a fazer
Odontologia entrei na faculdade de
odontologia pessoal eu fiquei eu fiquei
eu falo para vocês parece que foi no
piloto automático eu fiquei 4 anos na
faculdade de odontologia a faculdade de
odontologia são 9 períodos são quatro
anos e meio fiquei 4 anos quando eu tava
no último período eu já estava fazendo
vários atendimentos praticamente
trabalhando um passo dentro da profissão
ah ah eu estava fazendo um atendimento
em posto de saúde aqui em Belo Horizonte
e aí é ao final da manhã de atendimento
eu tava botando os meus materiais para
esterilizar e eu comecei a me imaginar
fazendo aquilo para o resto da vida eu
comecei a imaginar qual seria o meu
futuro provável se eu continuasse
fazendo aquilo que eu tava fazendo na
noite anterior eu não dormi e falei eu
vou acordar amanhã e vou ter esse
pensamento e o que que esse pensamento
me gerou me gerou uma angústia uma
tristeza porque eu percebi que eu não
estava construindo uma vida que eu
queria viver não é difícil você começar
a imaginar seu futuro fazendo que você
tá fazendo hoje
tá fazendo O que tá fazendo hoje você
vai chegar no destino que você deseja
chegar ou você entrou no piloto
automático por influência do seu meio o
seu meio te amo o seu meio tenta te
proteger na maioria das vezes a sua
família e ali você aceita essa
influência e você entra no piloto
automático e quando se acorda começa a
imaginação Porto por o açucar Nossa não
tô indo não estou construindo não estou
caminhando para uma vida que eu desejo e
aí eu cheguei diante deste
questionamento e eu falei nossa eu não
quero essa vida essa vida que eu é que
eu estou construindo aqui não a vida que
eu quero eu ainda não fechou os para
milhares de pessoas e o bolsinho em eu
ainda não Vivi uma história na música
igual sonhei uma história quando era a
criança
Oi e eu tomei uma decisão a no final dos
atendimentos lá depois que eu tava
colocando material para esterilizar o
falei assim vou para faculdade trancar
minha matrícula E eu pensei Pela Minha
experiência ninguém eu acho que até hoje
que todas as pessoas que eu falei isso
ninguém acredita todo mundo fala assim é
porque você não terminou eu saí do Posto
Saúde fui até a secretaria da minha
faculdade e cheguei lá e falei óleo vim
trancar minha matrícula Esse é um país
engraçado foi que a moça que tava lá
falou assim pera aí hoje é o último dia
olha para vocês verem hoje é o último
dia possível te trancar matrícula se eu
ficasse mais um dia eu não poderia era
obrigado a terminar o semestre já tinha
quase dois meses de aula e aí eu peguei
e falei olha então cheguei no dia certo
a moça tentou me convencer a desistir
você falou com seus pais você falou que
sua família você falou que você tá que
que você tá fazendo
os melhores sou maior de idade que uma
decisão Minho Traz esse documento que eu
quero assinar E aí ela é trouxe esse
documento e eu assinei e parece que ao
mesmo tempo que me colocou uma pressão
enorme porque eu não sabia quais os
desafios que estavam por vir a me deu
uma Lívio me deu um era como se eu se eu
pegasse um papel em branco com a
possibilidade de construir aquilo que eu
sonhava quando eu era quando eu era
criança e parece que as coisas começaram
a convergir ao meu favor a mesma banda
que eu tinha no ensino médio tava
vivendo o mesmo questionamento que o meu
e eu liguei para eles olha vamos voltar
com a banda e ele já estava numa
situação horrível na faculdade que eles
foram tomando muito pau já tava no meio
é só falar cara eu estou travado aqui no
meio da faculdade eu vou sair bora
trabalhar com música Gente em quatro
meses eu estava tocando na
os maiores casas de shows em Belo
Horizonte e fazendo shows para milhares
de pessoas há na região de Minas em
quatro meses em quatro meses do dia que
eu saí do Posto Saúde e tranquei a
faculdade eu estava realizando aquele
sonho que eu tive na infância e foi
fácil foi fácil quebrar essa resistência
enfrentar todo mundo enfrentar minha
família enfrentar todo mundo que estavam
ao redor para falar olha não quero
faculdade Meu foco fazer atividades
direcionadas para música que é o que eu
quero construir na minha vida
se você você que está vendo aqui se você
continuar fazendo o que você tá fazendo
hoje você vai chegar no futuro que você
deseja ou você foi influenciado
influenciada e tá no piloto automático
para uma vida construindo uma vida que
você não deseja e eu falei aqui com
vocês que o meu futuro provável eu
imaginei ele duas vezes a primeira vezes
primeira vez foi mais difícil a segunda
vez foi mais fácil Vocês ouviram no
início dessa apresentação é que eu sou
empresário eu tô contando uma história
aqui da minha trajetória como músico eu
fiquei dois anos no palco fiz mais de
200 200 shows fechou os para mais 10 mil
pessoas e no meio no meio da desse dessa
vida de músico e eu descobri um outro
desejo que eu tinha eu cuidava de toda a
parte comercial estratégica da minha
banda
hoje me peguei muito mais a interessado
com maiores desejo de ser um grande
empresário do que ser um grande músico
eu comecei a admirar grandes empresários
porque eu estudava técnica de venda
técnicas de marketing para aumentar a
venda do nosso show aumentar nosso
faturamento e eu me peguei apaixonado
por isso muito mais do que tá melhorando
no meu instrumento melhorando como
guitarrista e eu falei nossa
e eu comecei a admirar aqueles caras no
palco da mesma forma que eu admirava a
grandes músicos quando era pequeno ali
no meio da minha carreira como músico
comecei a admirar grandes empresários
que eu falei o desejo se o empresário e
aí eu comecei se eu desejo o empresário
que eu não tenho que fazer atividades
que o músico faz eu comecei a imaginar o
meu futuro provável e eu tomei uma
decisão porque foi uma segunda divisão
decisão não foi tão difícil contra
primeiro não enfrentei tanta resistência
para isso porque eu já estava mais
preparado mentalmente cheguei para mim a
banda reunir falei estou fora fora dos
palcos agora vou cuidar da nossa empresa
o que dá nosso negócio que eu quero me
tornar um grande empresário e tudo gente
tudo porque eu eu escolhi imaginar o meu
futuro e eu não deixei o meu meio
inclusive uma dica para vocês
e é nesses períodos que eu começava a
refletir sobre o meu futuro eu procurava
ficar sozinho porque a pior coisa a
gente muito influenciado influenciável
gente é muito influenciável e a a gente
tem que sair desse meio de influência
para que a gente consiga enxergar o que
a gente realmente quer se libertar eu me
isolava mesmo eu me isolava e começava
assistir conteúdo a consumir conteúdo
das pessoas que o desejavam me tornar
para eu ficar motivado e inspirado para
tomar a decisão de enfrentar o precisa
ser enfrentado para eu chegar nesse novo
destino o questionamento que eu quero
fazer aqui com vocês o que eu quero
inspirar o meu propósito com essa
apresentação eu quero que vocês parem e
pense
e o que que vocês estão fazendo hoje as
atividades que vocês estão fazendo hoje
na vida de vocês tá te levando para a
vida que você sonha a faculdade que você
tá fazendo hoje você escolheu tá na
faculdade ou foi a sua família que
escolheu o que que você realmente quer
do seu futuro você está caminhando para
o futuro porque se você tiver torcendo
se eu tiver torcendo para o final de
semana chegar igual Eu torcia durante a
faculdade se você tiver torcendo para
chegar as férias você tinha ficando
louco para acabar suas aulas tem alguma
coisa errada Pode ser que me deseja o
seu profundo de acontecer era
adolescente ele escondeu o esconderam
ele de você
bom então Imagina isso Qual é o seu
futuro provável E mude as suas
atividades de hoje para um destino que
você deseja obrigado tá